Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin der Narcid.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Nachname-Gespräch durchführen.
Können Sie bitte sagen, Sie sind mir bescheid.
Sie sind damit einverschuldigt?
Ja, klar.
Sehr gut. Können Sie bitte mir sagen, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Anna Kehl.
Anna Kehl. Frau Kehl, können Sie bitte Ihren Namen und Nachtnamen mischtabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist einfach A-L-L-A.
Und der Familienname ist K-I-H-L.
Ja, wunderbar.
Frau Anna, Frau Kehl, ich möchte die Daten zusammen.
Danach werden wir über Ihren aktuellen Bespäden sprechen.
Okay.
Wunderbar. Wie heißen Sie Frau Kehl?
Oder wie jung sind Sie?
Ich bin 67 Jahre.
Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 9.07.56.
Sechs.
50.
Ja, okay.
Frau Kehl, können Sie bitte mir sagen, wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m und ich wiege so 79 kg.
79 kg.
Ja, ich habe solche kräftigen Schmerzen so oben im Bauch.
Ich habe mich auch schon übergeben.
Mir ist richtig schlecht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich plötzlich jetzt gekommen.
Die Schmerzen werden immer schlimmer statt.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben sich übergeben.
Wie viel?
Und seit wann können Sie bitte mir sagen?
Ja, ich habe, also das ist eigentlich der Grund,
weshalb ich komme, weil ich mich auch übergeben musste.
Und zwar, das ist jetzt heute gewesen,
dass ich jetzt wieder in der Nähe bin.
Das ist jetzt heute gewesen, dass ich zweimal mich übergeben musste.
Und gestern ist mir aufgefallen, dass mein Stuhlgang ganz komisch aussieht.
Das sah so ganz dunkel aus.
Und eigentlich habe ich so ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen schon seit Tagen.
Aber jetzt wird das immer schlimmer.
Und ganz schlimm ist es, eigentlich nach dem Essen,
dann habe ich richtig heftig gesperrt.
Ja, okay.
Etwas bestimmter Essen oder so.
Das ist egal, weil mir so schlecht ist,
habe ich eigentlich schon nicht so viel gegessen.
Aber so, das weiß ich, normales Brot oder Gemüse und Kartoffeln oder so.
Ja, hinterher wird es immer schlimmer.
Okay, okay, darf ich fragen,
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Beschwerden, grüßt sich heute angefangen.
Es war genau, haben die Schmerzen angefangen.
Also die Schmerzen haben schon länger angefangen,
aber jetzt sind sie plötzlich schlechter geworden, ne?
Also, so ein bisschen Bauchweh habe ich schon seit Tagen.
Aber da habe ich halt gedacht, ich habe etwas Verkehrtes gegessen oder so.
Aber jetzt ist es eben mit einmal so schlimm geworden.
Und eben als dann auch noch dieses Übergeben dazu kam
und als dann der Stuhlgang so merkte, würde ich außer,
da habe ich gedacht, jetzt muss ich doch mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gut gemacht, eine sehr gute Entscheidung gemacht.
Frau Kehl, so, Sie haben auch,
Ihnen ist übel richtig?
Ja, schlecht ist mir ganz gut.
Auch seit ein paar Tagen?
Das ist jetzt eigentlich vermehrt, so seit zwei Tagen, ja.
Ja, okay.
So, seit zwei Tagen, können Sie mir sagen, Sie haben ähnliche Beschwerden oder?
Also wie gesagt, seit zwei Tagen fällt mir das auf,
dass das schlechter wird.
Oder mehr.
Ja, okay.
Seit wann haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Seit zwei Tagen oder vielleicht mehr?
Nee, nee, seit zwei Tagen ist das schlechter geworden, ja.
Okay, so schlechter geworden, aber seit wann haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ach so, ja, diese Bauchschmerzen habe ich jetzt eigentlich seit,
ja, vielleicht zwei Wochen oder so.
Aber da bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen, weil ich gedacht habe,
es geht schon wieder weg, aber es wird gar nicht besser.
Okay, es ist nicht immer da, es ist, können Sie mir sagen,
amfallsartig?
Nein, eigentlich ist es schon sauerhaft.
Dauerhaft.
Ja, okay, so seit zwei Tagen dauerhaft, oder?
Bei zwei Tagen ist immer da, richtig?
Ja, okay.
Wie stark ist diese Schmerzen, Frau Kehl, in einer Schmerzkala 0 bis 10,
wobei nur keine Schmerzen, in 10, 6 stark geschmerzen, entsprechen Sie.
Also inzwischen würde ich schon sagen, also zwischen 5 und 10,
also bei 7 vielleicht.
Zwischen 5 bis 7, richtig?
Nein, also ich würde sagen bei 7, also schon, ich habe überlegt,
also es ist über der Hälfte jedenfalls, aber da so in der Mitte,
also bei 7 würde ich sagen.
Ja, ich stöße mich.
Nachdem ich mich übergeben habe, habe ich das Gefühl,
da geht es mir ein kleines bisschen besser.
Wunderbar, wunderbar.
So, ein bisschen leichter.
Ja, okay, so, es immer, Sie haben gesagt,
die Schmerzen, dauerhaft, ist immer wie 7 oder es ist wie wellenförmig,
manchmal 5, manchmal 6 oder die können wir schreiben.
Nein, ich würde schon, also wie gesagt, direkt da, wenn ich mich übergeben habe,
sind die Schmerzen ein bisschen besser, sind sie vielleicht bei 6 oder 5,
aber sonst würde ich schon sagen, dass die bei 7 sind, also jetzt seit gestern.
Seit gestern, okay, so früher, früher, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben
ein bisschen Waden, seit 3 Wochen.
Ja, das war doch nicht so schlimm, sonst wäre ich eher gekommen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
So, Frau Ke, haben Sie die Atem weg?
Was habe ich?
Luftnot, haben Sie Luftnot?
Luftnot habe ich nicht, ich muss so ein bisschen...
Ich muss so ein bisschen rufen.
Ja, da kommt aber nichts raus, und ich bin auch nicht erkältet.
Okay, so, jetzt ist diese Husten mit Auswursch oder Druck?
Nein, da kommt nichts raus.
Ach, so, Druck.
Okay, so, Sie haben keine Atemnot.
Nein.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus, Frau Ke?
Nein, das ist alles hier oben so auf den Bauch beschränkt.
Okay, linken, rechts, rechts, oder ganz...
Meter.
Okay, haben Sie...
außer Essen haben Sie etwas bemerkt, die Ihnen beschwerten,
Schlechteitssinn, vielleicht Belastung, oder?
Ja, ich habe jetzt die Tage nicht mehr viel gemacht,
weil es mir einfach nicht gut geht.
Ich habe nicht so schlapp gefühlt,
denn habe ich nur so rum gesessen, ein bisschen die Füße hochgelegt,
aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen,
insbesondere nach dem Essen war es schlechter.
Ja, ich... okay.
So, Frau Ke, haben Sie etwas anzuschwärten,
haben Sie Fieber, vielleicht?
Also, ich fühle mich ein bisschen heiß, ja,
aber ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen.
Ja, die Beiß hoch, aber nicht gemessen.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe ja nicht gemessen,
aber jetzt, wenn Sie mich so fragen,
habe ich das Gefühl, dass mir so ein bisschen heiß ist, ja.
Ja, Sie haben jetzt bemerkt.
Ja, okay.
So, Frau Ke, haben Sie Probleme mit Schulgang oder Beinwürstelassen?
Na ja, im Augenblick habe ich natürlich schon Probleme mit dem Stuhl,
ich sagte ja, dass das so komisch aussieht.
Aber sonst, normalerweise, ja gut,
muss manchmal nachts auch die Toilette, ja,
aber sonst geht das wohl.
Okay, seit wann müssen Sie nachts auf die Toilette gehen?
Schon lange, schon viele Jahre, ja, einmal in der Nacht mal.
Okay, ich möchte, okay, ich wurde gar nicht verstanden,
haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang auch,
oder Verstopfung?
Normalerweise nicht, Durchfall oder Verstopfung habe ich nicht,
aber wie gesagt, mir ist aufgefallen,
dass das so komisch aussieht.
Was komisch aussieht?
Ja, ich habe die Duskelstuhlgang.
Aha, okay, okay, ich habe mir jetzt gesagt.
Wie rot oder schwarz?
Eher fast schwarz.
Schwarz.
Seit wann?
Ja, seit gestern.
Seit gestern.
Aha, okay.
Frau Ke, haben Sie Apetitlosigkeit?
Ja, im Augenblick brauche ich nicht viel zu essen,
es schmeckt mir überhaupt nichts.
Sie haben Apetitlosigkeit?
Weil ich diese Bauchsmärzen habe, ne?
Ja, wegen Bauchspeise.
Aha, auch seit zwei Tagen, oder?
Ja, eigentlich schon ein bisschen länger,
dass ich eigentlich nicht so richtig gerne esse, ja.
Aber ich habe das auch auf die Wärme geschoben,
es waren jetzt auch warme Tage,
und dann, ja, da hat man halt nicht so viel Hunger.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
So, haben Sie Gewichtsverdannung bemerkt?
Ja, was ich gemerkt habe, ich habe in den letzten Monaten,
aber also jetzt nicht kurz, fast nicht,
habe ich ein bisschen zugenommen,
ich muss wegen meiner Arthritis,
ich habe so eine rheumatische Arthritis
und da muss ich Koalitions-Nähmung
nehmen und da habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich jetzt mit einmal zunehme,
dass ich so Wasserallen lahre.
Aha, so, okay, Sie haben Wasserallen, ja.
Wo genau?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe so das Gefühl,
dass ich eben schwerer bin und dass ich im Gesicht
gespollen bin und an den Händen und an den Füßen
und am Bauch und überall.
Okay, okay, über, dann, okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Nein, okay, okay, so, okay,
haben Sie vielleicht Schlafstörungen, oder?
Ja, jetzt, also die letzten Nächte habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen
mit den Bauchschmerzen,
dann habe ich mich auch jetzt endlich aufgemacht zu Ihnen,
weil mir das alles ein bisschen unheimlich war.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Also Frau Kehl, haben Sie Krebel oder Taubheit gefühlt?
Was habe ich?
Krebel, Gefühl oder Taubheit gefühlt?
Wo habe ich das?
In irgendwelche Körper.
Körper, habe ich keinen Krebel oder Taubheit gefühlt? Nein.
Okay, ja, Taubheit, Gefühl, okay, gut.
So, haben Sie andere Beschwerden vielleicht,
Frau Kehl, von denen ich wissen soll, oder so?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen noch jetzt eigentlich alles gesagt,
was mir, also, ja, also ich habe,
ich habe diese Bauchschmerzen, ich musste mich übergeben,
mir ist schlecht, es schmeckt mir nicht.
So, waren Sie, ja, ich verstehe,
waren Sie schon einmal beim Haushalts gewesen
wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Ja, deswegen dieser Sache nicht, nein, nein, nein.
Da bin ich jetzt direkt gekommen,
weil das mit einmal so schlimm geworden ist.
Ja, haben Sie eine Beschwerde mit einer eigenen Genom
wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Nein, ich habe, ich habe meistens versucht,
dass ich ein bisschen Tee trinke und habe mir meine Wärmflasche
aufgelegt, aber das hat alles nicht geholfen.
Ja, okay, so.
Nicht geholfen.
Okay, so, eine Beschwerde.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben aromatische,
aromatische Arturitis, richtig?
Seit wann?
Das hat man vor zehn Jahren festgestellt.
Vor zehn Jahren, okay.
Haben Sie andere Erdrankungen auch oder nur das?
Ja, ein bisschen hohen Blut hoch habe ich auch.
Okay, seit wann?
Ja, das hat man auch so vor zehn Jahren,
hat man mich vor Augen Kopf gestellt
und da hat man das alles festgestellt.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden,
Vorerkrankungen auch oder diese zwei?
Nein, also diese Rheumagesichte und Bluthofe.
Diese Rheume ist extrem unangenehmer,
diese Arturitis, ne?
Ja, ja, natürlich, ja, ich verstehe.
So, Sie nehmen Cortisol.
Ich nehme ja Kretny Solone.
Kretny Solone, ja.
Wie viel Millikram und wie viel Microsolone?
Das sind 15 Milligramm und nehme ich eine morgens.
Eine morgens, okay, eine mal morgens.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche andere Medikamente?
Ja, Kaptofilene.
Kaptofilene, ne?
Wie viel Millikram?
Da steht 25 drauf, dann nehme ich eine morgens, eine Abend.
Ja, okay, okay, appreciate.
So, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, okay?
Ja, ich hatte mal, ach, das ist aber schon Ewigkeiten her,
wurde mal am Knie operiert, da hatte ich ein Holzbandriss.
Das ist, da war ich 18, also sehr lange her.
Sie waren 18, ja okay.
Welche Knie, welche seid?
Das rechte Knie.
So, warum Sie haben, Sie wurden operiert?
Bitte?
Was passiert, warum wurden Sie operiert?
Ich hatte ein Holzbandriss.
Ach, okay, okay, Kreuzbandriss, ja, ja, okay, verstehe.
So, andere Operationen auch?
Ne, sonst finde ich nicht operiert worden.
Ja, okay.
Was ist die Komplikation auch, geträgt sind?
Ja, Maas, nee, nicht, dass ich verstehe.
Alles okay.
Keine Komplikation, das ist sehr gut.
So, okay, sind Sie allergisch?
Ja, die finde ich weiß, habe ich keine allergischen.
Nee, aber bisher ist nichts bekannt.
Ja, ich verstehe.
So, haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Was habe ich?
Unverträglichkeit.
Ja, ich kann nicht alles, was da ist.
Die Laptopinfoil-Ensruhe.
Aber ich habe jetzt nichts, was ich nicht essen darf, oder so.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
So, Frau Kehl, brauchen Sie?
Ja, brauchen tu ich schon ziemlich lange, ja.
Ja, wie viel brauchen Sie, und seit wann?
Ja, ich rauch so ein Päckchen am Tag seit 30 Jahren.
Ein paar guck, meinen Sie?
Ja, seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Okay, so, das ist so viel im Empfehle.
Ja.
Ich empfehle Ihnen eine Kotin, Karrens.
Ja, so, Frau Kehl, vielleicht, haben, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja, abends trinken wir oft mal ein Glas Malen, ja.
Täglich?
Nein, aber vielleicht so drei, vier Mal in der Woche, jeden zweiten Tag.
Okay, zwei, vier Mal.
Okay, zwei Mal.
Okay, Frau Kehl, bitte nehmen Sie nichts persönlich,
die seine Standortmusik gefragt haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt, nein.
Ja, wunderbar.
So, Frau Kehl, darf ich fragen, sind Sie für heiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Ja, okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind jetzt schon erwachsen, aber ja, ich hatte zwei Kinder, ja.
Sie sind gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Ja, wunderbar.
So, was machen Sie für die Frau Kehl?
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Sie sind Hausfrau.
Okay, kann ich fragen, ist bei, ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, oder wenn Sie haben ein Schleppeschwister?
Mein Vater ist verstorben, der hatte in hohem Alter ein Herzinfarkt.
Und meine Mutter, sie lebt doch hochbetagt, aber die ist natürlich altersbedingt,
das ist auch nicht mehr fit.
Okay, hat sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen auch?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, vielleicht hat sie ein bisschen Wünschhochdruck
oder vielleicht hat sie auch ein bisschen Diabetes, aber also,
das ist nicht, dass sie jetzt viele Medikamente nehmen muss oder so.
Ja, ich verstehe.
So, wie alt war Ihr Vater, Frau Kehl, wenn sie gestorben ist?
Mein Vater, als er gestorben ist, der war 82.
82, okay mein Weihnacht.
Frau Kehl, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Brüder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Brüder, ja, ja, so viel ich weiß, so viel Kontakt haben wir nicht.
Ja, wunderbar, nicht so viel Kontakt.
Okay, da ist viel Frau und Frau Kehl, Sie haben gesagt,
seit wann haben Sie Wusten?
Ach, das habe ich glaube ich schon lange.
Ich würde sagen, bestimmt schon sechs Wochen,
dass ich immer so ein bisschen höchsteln muss, ja.
Ja, okay, seit sechs Wochen, Sie haben gesagt,
ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen, haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen?
Ja, also Frage ist natürlich,
was machen Sie gegen meine Schmerzen, was kann man dagegen tun
und woher kommt es, dass das mit einmal solche Schmerzen ist?
Ja, ja, ist mir so leicht, ja.
Jetzt, Frau Kehl, ich möchte Sie körperlich untersuchen
und ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Ja, ich möchte meine Einparts anderer Untersuchungen durchführen.
Danach, ich werde Ihnen etwas sagen, ich habe ein bisschen mehr.
Danach können Sie mir mehr sagen, nach den Untersuchungen.
Ja, danach, ich kann Ihnen mehr sagen.
Ja, Sie können mir mehr sagen.
Okay, ja, gut.
Sind das denn jetzt irgendwie schmerzhafte Untersuchungen,
die Sie mit mir machen?
Nein, gar nicht, ja, es ist nicht Schmerzhaft.
Ich habe schon herbexagt, ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben keine Angst wegen Nadeln.
Ja, einmal kiechst du, wenn Sie so schlimm sind.
Und danach, ich möchte eine Bauch-Ustrasche durchführen.
Es dauert circa zehn Minuten, total schmerzlos,
riesigfrei verfahren.
Mit unserer Schein, wir können Ihre Bauchorganen beurteilen.
Ja, das klingt so eine Musik, ja.
Ja, und ich möchte Sie untersuchen, körperlich.
Ich möchte Ihre Untersuchungen und Herz abhören.
Ja, klar.
Ihre Bauchtasten, ja, und körperlich.
Ich meine, haben Sie andere Fragen an mich?
Okay.
Nein, dann warte ich jetzt hier auf Sie, oder?
Ja, genau, bitte, warte, hier nicht.
Wenn wir brauchen mehr Untersuchungen,
dann werde ich Ihnen bescheid sagen.
Ja, super.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Oh, gleich, mir auch.
Guten Abend, Frau Kind.
Hallo.
Haben Sie Magenschutz-Tablette eingenommen wegen dieser Prednisol-Nol-Tablette?
Nein.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was Magenschutz ist.
Okay, ich meine, wie Panthaprosol.
Nein, ich habe nur, was ich gesagt habe, diese Tabletten nehme ich.
Also da ist ja kein Magenschutz dabei.
Okay, und nehmen Sie wegen der Gelenkschmerzen-Nol-Prednisol-Nol-Tablette?
Oder manchmal auch Igbu-Profen oder Dick-Löfen-Aknem-ich manchmal noch?
Ja.
Dick-Löfen-Aknem-ich, okay.
Haben Sie früher Sotbrennen oder Sauers aufgestossen?
Das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen, kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Trinken Sie viel Kaffee?
Ja, vielleicht so 3 Tassen am Tag.
Morgen zwei und nachmittags machen wir eine.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen Hautfarb-Präsidentin aufgefallen, wie die gelbe Augen?
Nein, das habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Okay, und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zwei Mal heute Morgen übergeben müssten?
Ja, ganz fraglich.
Wie ist das aus dieser Erbrechen?
Ja, das war natürlich Essensreste und dann so gelbliches Zeug.
Da war aber auch ein bisschen blutiger Schlein mit dabei.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter Herzstrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, mein Puls ist ganz normal.
Ich kontrolliere das nicht so oft.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Danke.
Frau Kern, fühlen Sie sich müde oder schwindel?
Mühde fühle ich mich schon so schlapp, ja.
Besonders seit zwei Tagen?
Ja, besonders seit zwei Tagen, also normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Aber jetzt in diesen Tagen fühle ich mich wirklich schlapp.
Und...
Schwindeln auch?
Bitte?
Nein, ich schwindel nicht. Das würde ich nicht sagen.
Danke.
Noch ein bisschen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Die Schmerzen, die ich nicht mehr habe, sind sehr dumm, stecken, brennen...
Ich würde sie eher als dumpf bezeichnen, ja.
So als drückend dumpf.
Danke schön.
Aber eben sehr heftig, ne?
Ich habe die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel, nach dem Essen,
sind plöstisch angefangen oder aufgetreten oder...
Also nach dem Essen verschlechtern Sie sich?
Ja, nach dem Essen verschlechtern sie sich.
Ja, aber Sie haben natürlich irgendwann mal schleichend angefangen.
Man merkt ja nicht sofort, also man merkt dann mit einem,
wenn man es tut, aber irgendwie weh.
Und dann merkt man, dass es immer schlimmer wird.
Und jetzt ist es eben so, dass es so besonders schlecht ist,
direkt nach dem Essen.
Und als ich dann jetzt heute Morgen mich übergeben habe,
hatte ich das Gefühl, jetzt ist es ein bisschen ruhig.
Na, jetzt ist es ein klein bisschen besser.
Und als ich dann aber wieder versucht habe, was zu essen,
war es wieder schlechter.
Danke schön.
Können wir erst als
Sie das jetzt mal vorstellen?
Haben Sie seit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, Frau Keh, 67-jährige Patientin hat sich bei uns wegen
plöstlich aufgetretener Abwehrbeaufschmerzen.
Sie hat nicht besonders seit wann.
Danach hat sie mir gesagt, seit zwei Tagen
ein je beschwerden, aber eigentlich hat sie,
ah, es tut mir so leid, ich muss alle Patientin dazu sagen.
Ja, sie ist 67 Jahre alt geboren,
am 17, 1956, 1,68 m groß, 79 kg schwer.
Sie hat sich bei uns wegen plöstlich aufgetretener
Abwehrbeaufschmerzmitte vorgestellt.
Sie hat ein je beschwerden seit zwei Wochen,
aber die Schmerzen haben sich in falle auch derzeit
verschlechtert, besonders seit, seit,
seit zwei Tagen.
Seit drei Tagen, okay.
Seit den letzten zwei Tagen.
Heute, sie hat sich zwei Mal übergeben.
Wie nennen wir das?
Ich...
Imesis.
Okay, es war eszten Resten und Blutik.
Wie nennen wir das dann?
Blutik und esz... ja, Hematemes.
Ja, Hematemes.
Ja, weil wir müssen bestätigen.
Ja, das muss man checken.
Die Schmerzen sind dumpf, druckend.
Ja, ich will gleich auch zwei Fragen...
Strahlen die Schmerzen aus?
Nein, keine Astralium.
Die Schmerzen in der Technik sind 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Übergeben, ja, ich meine,
imesis hat die Beschwerden erleichtert.
Okay.
Nach dem, nach dem imesis,
Schmerzintanz steht, ist die Liege
bei 6,6 von 10.
Patienten habe seit,
seit sechs Wochen Husten
keine Auswuchs.
Die Frage nach Stuhl, Stuhl,
Stuhl hat dunkel geworden.
Stuhl ist dunkel geworden, wie nennen wir das?
Ja, ich schuldige mich,
ich habe nie gefragt, ist es hell...
Es ist schwarz,
deswegen können wir sagen, Melena.
Ja, genau.
Seit wann habt ihr Melena?
Seit gestern.
Ja, also zwei Tagen.
Sie habe Nocturie seit viele Jahren,
einmal,
einmal, ja, einmal
nachts, ja, sie muss auf die Toilette
und habe Appetitlosigkeit
wegen Bauchschmerzen seit gestern.
Ja, klar.
Ja, und hat
Ödem besachnet
in alle Körperregionen,
besonders in Gesichtshand, Bauch,
Überreis, habe Schlafschtörungen,
wegen Schmerzen.
Woher, was beschreibt sie mit dem Ödem?
Ja, Wasser, Wasser, Anlagierung
im Gesichtshand, Bauch, Überreis.
Ja, aber da hat sie ja etwas dazu gesagt.
Ich schuldige,
ja, das ist eine Frage.
Was hat die Patente gesagt?
Es gibt eine Ursache für diese Wasseranlagierung.
Was vermutet sie denn?
Aha, ja, sie hat gesagt,
vielleicht die Gegend romatisch Artritis.
Sie nehmen Prednisolone ein.
Sie hat gesagt, viel dafür wegen das.
Ja, also, nicht, dass sei die Ursache,
aber sie hat es nicht angemessen.
Ja, nicht gemessen.
Eigentlich hat sie gesagt, gerade bemerkt.
Und Ragen nach
Griebelgefühl, Taup-Reitgefühl
wurden verneint.
Ja, genau, ja.
Und ja, sie ist, sie fühlt sich fieberig,
aber sie hat nicht angemessen.
Sie wurde verneint.
Ja, und ja, Müdigkeit
seit zwei Tagen, haben wir Müdigkeit seit zwei Tagen.
Ja, auch Schmerzen sind postbrandärisch.
Am meisten kreiten nach dem Essen auf.
Ja, das sagt sie.
Ja, vor Erkrankungen, die Patienten
haben eine
leide an romatisch-romatisch Artritis seit
zehn Jahren.
Sie nehmen Prednisolone 15 Milligramm,
einmal pro Tag dagegen.
Und sie haben die Liefertonie vor
seit zehn Jahren auch, nehmen
Kaptobrilf, 75 Milligramm,
zweimal pro Tag, einmal morgen, einmal nachts.
Und auch die Klophanak bei Bedarf.
Ja, vor Opis, sie wurde einmal
an, wurde einmal Knieoperation
gehabt, wurde an Knieoperiz
mit dem 18. Lebensjahr, ohne Komplikation.
Den acht Drübenz, ja, okay.
Ja, und nach dem letzten Lebensjahr.
Keine Allergie und Verklicke
bei der Patientin bekannt.
Ja, noch, noch sind Geschichte.
Nikotin Abousus, ein Packung pro Tag
seit 30 Jahren, mit dem 37-Packung-Jahr.
Erkohlkonsum, zwei bis drei
gelese Wein,
zwei Wochen, keine trockenen Konsum.
Sie ist bei Hausfrau, sie ist
bei Verheiratssitz, habe zwei Kinder,
beide sind gesund.
Familie, eine mnestische Vater
ist am,
herrs, in Fakt gestorben.
Sie ist in der
Familie gestorben, mit
82 Lebensjahr.
Mutter, ja, Mutter, ja, es ist,
die Patientin hat mir unklare
Informationen gegeben,
vielleicht Mutter, Leide
an Arterie-Repersonin, Diabetes, aber sie war nicht sicher.
Aber die Mutter lebt.
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Ja, genau.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Magen, umkürzt man sich cool sein?
Mmh.
Definitiv.
Was kann es sein?
Reismagen.
Syntronpreis zahlen.
Noch mal, bitte.
Reisdagen.
Reisdagen?
Ich tabelkomme Syntron.
Auf jeden Fall, wir möchten
akut korreter Syntron ausschließen.
Was müssen wir ausschließen?
Akut korreter Syntron.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber
worauf, worauf
deuten denn die Symptome
eigentlich am deutlichsten
hin?
Ja.
Äh, gibt es
Melena.
Genau.
Und sie hat auch Hematemesis.
Ja, Hematemesis.
Ähm, ja, es ist
problematisch, garstrunden
Syntron.
Garstrunden Syntron, system.
Äh, ja, es kann.
Aber also wahrscheinlich eher
nicht unten im Garm,
sondern eher weiter.
Ja, genau, genau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall Maden, weil es ist Melena.
Ja, es ist die Modelle.
Was machen Sie die Diagnostik mit der Patientin?
Äh, ich, ja, äh,
Körperlinker-Suchung,
Stationeraffnahme,
sofort.
kann, äh, kann
eine Blutung
sein.
Mal eine Blutung sein.
Ja, genau.
Äh, ähm,
das ist allererstes.
Wunach gucken Sie als allererstes.
Die Patientin hat
starke Schmerzen, ist ein bisschen schlaff.
Sie
vom Publikum
möglicherweise auf ein akutes Corona-Sum.
Eine EKG.
Ja, eine EKG,
eine EKG, für die
Vitalparameter,
ja, genau, Vitalparameter,
äh, ja.
Und dann machen Sie
körperliche Untersuchungen weiter,
wie machen Sie bei der
körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ähm,
ja, äh,
Bauch, ähm,
Bauch-Untersuchung,
Bauch-Unterschlechtung.
Auf eine Stelle, ja.
Was machen Sie da?
Äh,
ich bin nicht sicher,
ich gebe es ein. Ja, Sie machen doch
erst mal eine körperliche
Untersuche.
Ich habe es erst mal benutzen Sie Ihre Augen
und gucken, wie die Patientin an.
Ja, genau.
Ja, Bauch, äh, abtasten.
Ja, ähm,
genau.
Und? Instektion,
so eine Instektion, ähm,
ja, äh,
Percussion, Perlpation.
Ja, Percussion, Perlpation, ja.
Sie gucken, ob die wirklich Ideen
hat.
Ja, genau, ja,
ja. Und Sie gucken, ob der Bauch
gebläht ist, ob der,
ob sie Anfestspannung hat, ne?
Also, gut, okay.
Ja, genau, ja,
ja, es ist, äh, Bauch-Untersuchung,
ähm,
es ist, ähm,
Merfisachen, äh,
Quasios,
wie kann man sagen, ähm,
Ausfultatour,
machen Sie oder was? Nein,
Seichen, ich meine, für, äh,
Merfisachen und, ähm,
Merfisachen, ja.
Merfisachen, McBurnie,
äh, auch Quasios,
so,
Quasios,
so, Zeichen, diese, ja,
für geilen Beladen, ähm,
Ah, okay, hm, hm.
Wie kann man sagen, wie wird?
Quasios,
wie wird, es ist so schwer zu sagen.
Ja, okay,
ich kenne die Untersuchung nicht, aber Sie
haben den Recht, haben Sie,
ja, gut, ähm, ja,
und, äh, Sie haben, der Patientin,
glaub ich, auch schon gesagt, Sie wollen
ein Ultraschall machen, ne? Ja,
genau, Bauch-Ultraschall. Ja,
gut, und, ähm,
was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Labortechnisch, ja, auf jeden Fall,
Ludwigs, ähm, ja,
Kardiögen,
Leberch, äh,
und Nieren, äh, Parameter,
äh, äh,
und was erwarten Sie im Blutbild?
Äh,
ja, eigentlich
hier ist Blutbild,
ist sehr wichtig, kann
Hemoglobin er niedrig sein,
wegen Blutung. Das wollte ich hören, ja.
Das würden wir erwarten, ja.
Ja, Fertig, Fertig,
ja, Fertig, äh,
auch, wir können,
ähm, gucken,
ähm,
Pakt, Enhymen,
Pankrans, Äh, Enzymen,
Pankrans-Wertchen, ich glaube,
ja, ja. Auch Brutzuka,
ist, auch, wir können,
ja, gut, also,
großes Labor, großes Programm,
und, äh,
dann haben Sie selber schon gesagt,
als technische Untersuchung, was würde
man da machen?
Äh, technische Untersuchung,
sind mal, mal, ähm,
die Bildgebände, Verfahren. Ja.
Ja, äh, ich bin sicher,
dass das Effekt,
oder nicht, weil
eine Perkuretion kann sein.
Ach so, ja, ja,
dann muss man von Befund abhängig machen,
vielleicht auch, was der Unverschaltung
von der Befund her gibt, ne?
Ja, ja,
und Verschaltung, Brutbild,
nicht impulsiv,
technisch wäre besser, vielleicht.
Und auch, äh, ja,
auf jeden Fall, gastro-radiologische
oder gegebenen Fall,
zürichische Konsum. Ja, genau.
Gut, ja,
dann, ähm,
bin ich gespannt,
machen Sie die,
angegene Untersuchung und informieren Sie
mich über die Frau Fehl,
und, ähm,
dann schauen wir nachher noch mal zusammen,
nach der Patientin, ja?
Äh, ich wollte,
ich wollte, ich wollte, ich wollte machen.
Wir beenden jetzt unser Gespräch,
schauen Sie nach der Patientin,
und wir besuchen
Frau Kehl, nachher noch
in ihrem Zimmer,
äh, wenn Sie die Untersuchung
durchgeführt haben, alles klar.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, möchte jemand noch was dazu sagen?
Ja, Einschädigung,
äh, Woran liegt
der Hustern,
Woran liegt der Hustern des Patientin?
Das weiß ich auch nicht so genau.
Möglicherweise
hat sie tatsächlich
doch so einen kleinen Reflux,
und ähm,
siehst du deswegen,
aber hat das nie so registriert.
Sie ist auch ja den Beigiedelit, aber
Stimmt, ja, sie raucht natürlich, klar.
Aber Hustern, ich leite
für sechs Wochen, ja, umspürtig.
Ja, es war sechs Wochen, aber
sehr neu. Ja, vielleicht hat es vorher nicht
registriert, ne? Ja, gut,
äh, Raucher
sind ja eigentlich immer kerngesund nach
den Aussagen, die haben ja nie irgendwelche
Bestärkendlöse rauchen.
Ja, gut, ähm,
ja, also was mir aufgefallen ist,
ähm,
sie sprechen unheimlich schnell.
Man hat
ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten
äh, ihnen zu folgen.
Au, Doktor.
Ja?
Ah, ja, was soll ich machen?
Ja, wirklich, ich weiß nicht.
Sie haben gemerkt, ich habe ein paar Mal
nachgefragt, weil ich wirklich
nicht verstanden habe,
was sie von mir wollen, ja.
Ja, genau.
Und, also sowohl als Patientin,
als auch, nachher
als Ärztin, konnte ich
manche Sachen nicht gut verstehen.
Äh, ich glaube sie
ähm,
sie können eigentlich, also sie
beherben die Sprache ganz gut.
Ähm, nur, wie gesagt,
es geht
irrsinnig schnell, ja.
Versuchen sie, ein bisschen Tempo rauszunehmen,
ja.
Was mir auffällt,
dass der Satzbau manchmal ein bisschen holprig ist,
äh, diese
berühmte Geschichte,
dann ich mache das und das
oder ähm,
ja, so die Reihenfolge stimmen manchmal nicht ganz,
aber ich würde sagen, das können wir vernachlässigen.
Ähm,
wo ich wirklich irritiert war
als Patientin,
ähm,
das war die Frage nach dem Taubheitsgefühl
oder nach einem Kribbelbesmüll.
Ähm, das
ähm, das würde man ja
am ehesten erwarten,
was, was ich in den Extremitäten,
oder?
Nein, ich werde
bitte?
Ja, in akut Coronar-Syndrom,
ähm,
Nein, nein, please.
Ich denke,
diese Frage
ist nicht
wirklich
genug.
Ist nicht genug? Ja.
Ja, äh,
diese Patientin ist,
äh, nicht nötig.
Nicht nötig.
Die Frage ist nicht nötig,
meinen Sie, okay? Ja, nicht nötig, ja.
Ja, also,
äh,
das ist ein Gefühl,
äh, habe ich natürlich bei Durchblutungsstörungen,
ja,
oder ähm,
ein Taubheitsgefühl,
oder bei Nerven-Versionen,
ja, aber davon ist hier jetzt ja
gerade nicht unbedingt auszugehen.
Ja, ähm,
insofern, ja,
würde ich auch sagen, ist das jetzt hier nicht so,
äh, wie wahrscheinlich,
das kann wahrscheinlich Dr. Gündiz am besten sagen,
wie wahrscheinlich ist das
ein Coronasyndrom bei dieser Symptomatik?
Äh,
die Patientin
Risikofaktören gibt es,
epigaziell,
Schmerzen,
äh,
Zunehmem,
zwei Tage,
Frauen,
67 Jahre,
zwei epigaziell Schmerzen,
drei und Raucher,
deswegen denken wir
immer akut Coronasyndrom
äh,
bei der Frau
und äh,
danach andere, äh, die finanzielle Diagnose
denken, aber nur die
finanzielle Diagnose, nur die finanzielle Diagnose.
Ja, ja, okay, gut.
Also, äh, würde man zunächst,
aber schon, sich kümmern um
diese potenzielle Blutung.
Na? Ja,
da war, also die Frau Dr. Gündiz schon
richtig auf dem Weg.
Ja.
Ähm,
wir, äh,
diese Simulation
immer eine Pferdaktdiagnose
denken müssen,
aber, äh,
normalerweise, äh,
im Alltag nicht diese,
äh, diese,
weil ein Patient,
diese Patient, äh,
Perforation,
Ulkustperforation und
Solokalte-Impfax zusammen
äh, eine Diagnose
möchte mir
stellen.
Ja, ähm, die Meinde könnte auch beides haben.
Ja, beides,
aber, äh, manchmal,
nicht immer.
Okay, aber... deswegen,
deswegen erstmal eine Pferdaktdiagnose,
äh, Pferdikulkusperforation,
äh, Differenzialdiagnose,
Akutis, Coronasendron,
Pankratitis, Galenstein
und so weiter.
Ja, ja, okay, gut.
Ja, ähm,
Frau Doktor, Sie sind immer wieder weg.
Kommt doch mal wieder zu mir.
Ja, äh,
ähm,
können Sie,
können Sie mit, mit den Infos was anfangen?
Wann, wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
15. August.
Ah ja, okay, gut.
Ja, äh, ja,
ich kann Ihnen im Augenblick nur den Rat geben,
nehmen Sie ein bisschen Tempo raus.
Ja?
Ja.
Dann, dann kann man Sie besser verstehen.
Ja?
Ist nicht so leicht, wenn man sich das angewöhnt hat
und, äh,
aber es wäre hilfreich,
ne, es wäre hilfreich.
Und ansonsten...
Ja, aber es würde Nachtfragen verhindern. Und Sie haben das gemerkt, ich habe manchmal direkt gleich interveniert und habe gleich gesagt, hey, das verstehe ich nicht.
Oder, also das waren dann die Stellen, wo die Schwachstellen sind. Da habe ich mich dann gleich korrigiert.
Gut, dann sind wir für heute, würde ich sagen, soweit. Ja?
Ja, danke schön.